une femme de terrain c'est comme cela
que se définit florence grand juge
assistant à la direction générale de
pôle emploi
elle s'est engagée en politique auprès
de la république en marche pour les
législatives
candidate dans la 12e circonscription
elle veut faire de l'emploi sa priorité
un domaine qu'elle connaît depuis 30 ans
j'ai donc été directrice d'agencé sur
différentes implantations des yvelines
et j'ai créé également l' agence pour
l'emploi de plaisir en 2001 pour
permette aux plaisirs war également aux
habitants de ben et saint germain de la
grange d'avoir un service pour l'emploi
de proximité l'emploi permet de toucher
tous les sujets et depuis maintenant
deux ans je travaille auprès du
directeur général adjoint de pôle emploi
issu de la société civile c'est sa
première expérience en politique mais
c'est un environnement qui lui est
familier j'ai l'habitude de travailler
avec les politiques
j'ai commencé tout jeune son département
des yvelines j'ai travaillé avec de
nombreuses personnalités politiques et
c'est particulièrement important lorsque
l'on travaille dans le domaine de
l'emploi qui est un sujet très sensible
de pouvoir travailler avec tous les
acteurs locaux
il fallait ouvrir à la société civile
l'assemblée nationale parce que la
politique je pense que c'est pas un
métier pour l'épauler dans sa campagne
son suppléant aymeric vallespir un
travail qu'elle veut complémentaire
c'est avec lui qu'elle a défini son
programme axé sur l'éducation la
sécurité ou les transports enrique
et très très par son parcours
professionnel par sa jeunesse de part
son appétence également via on dirait je
dirais qu'il est vraiment la personne
qui peut le mieux compléter ma
candidature
aujourd'hui nous faisons campagne
ensemble nous rencontrons les personnes
ensemble nous avons construit donc les
axes de notre programme ensemble est
également et bien notre réflexion et
construit quotidiennement florence
granger affrontera très autre candidat
pour cette élection
parmi eux le député sortant républicain
david douillet élu à près de 50 cent
pour cent en 2012